the graphs of f of X G of X and H of X
are shown below select and drag cards to
create a compound inequality that orders
the values of f of X G of X and H of X
for X values near to but not at 2 itself
so for any of the X values that are
depicted right over here say X is equal
to 3 we see that H of 3 is the largest F
of 3 is the smallest and G of 3 is in
between and that's true for any of the X
values that they've depicted here if we
look at if we look at when X is equal to
1 H of 1 is the largest F of 1 is the
smallest G of 1 is in between so for all
of the x values that they're depicting f
of X is less than or equal to G of X
which is less than which is less than or
equal to H of X and the only place where
the equal based on this graph comes into
play it looks like as we approach x
equals 2 it looks like they are all they
are all all the functions are
approaching 1 so that's where the equals
the equal might come into play but let's
keep seeing what they want us to do
after that so then it says it follows
that and instead of writing the f of X G
of X and H of X they've written the
actual definitions of them so let's just
remind ourselves f of X f of X is 2
times the square root of x minus 1 minus
1 that's this blue one right over here
so instead of writing f of X we can
write 2 times the square root of x minus
1 minus 1 is less than or equal to G of
X G of X was this rational expression
right over here so let's go dap back
down here it's that we get this rational
expression and that's going to be less
than or equal to H of X which was I
believe e to the X minus 2 is that right
yep e to the X minus 2 so because so all
I've really all we've really done is
replaced F G and H with their
definitions and then this means that the
limit so they're looking at the limit as
X approaches 2 of these different
expressions so the limit as X approaches
2 of this
expression is going to be less than or
equal to the limit as X approaches 2 of
this expression which is this right over
here which is going to be less than or
equal to the limit as X approaches 2 of
this expression which is that right over
there and then they say finally the
value of the limit as X approaches 2 of
this thing right over here is well this
is where the squeeze theorem comes into
play we just have to remind ourselves X
approaches 2 let's see 2 minus 1 so
we're taking the principal root of 2
minus 1 which is the principal root of 1
see if 2 times 1 minus 1 so this is 1
this right over here is e to the 2 minus
2 that's e to the 0 or that's 1 as well
so the limit of all of this is going to
be greater than or equal to 1 and it's
going to be less than or equal to 1 or
it's right in between 1 and 1 and the
only way that it's going to be 1 between
1 and 1 is if it is equal to 1 this is
the squeeze theorem at play right over
here G of X over the domain that we've
been looking at or over over over the X
values that we care about G of X was
less than or equal to H of X which was
or
f of X was less than or equal to G of X
which was less than or equal to H of X
and then we took the limit for all of
them as X approached 2 for the lower
function for f of X it approached 1 and
we see it in the graph right over here
and the lower function f of X approaches
1 H of X approaches 1 and therefore G of
X must also approach 1 and we actually
see that in this graph right over here
but anyway we could we could check our
answer just to feel good about ourselves
we got it right